you said that the Bro culture of
Entourage still exists you think that's
of course it still exists right to those
guys every night in Hollywood outside of
the Bro culture yeah 100 it still exists
yeah everywhere you look it's still
where you look oh all are you referring
to like how people always go on and on
about how misogynistic the show was
do they do that yes
constantly and you're you're upset by
that oh I think it's such horseshit
that's what the show was it was about a
bunch of these
but but but that was it the different
time a a different time B not that
different so what happened still now
like let's be real you know yeah it was
post me too but before me too yeah but
like
every week there's some new [ __ ]
that's you know has some is going going
down for something and so you know I
always just defended it I was like
I think I just always got sensitive
about it because I think people love to
hate on things that are working
and so someone's always going to say
something and the truth is that you know
Doug Ellen was a genius and Doug Allen
simply wrote about the [ __ ] that went on
and he did it in an entertaining fashion
so it's like you can [ __ ] on the show
or just like hate our business but he
was writing about our business like Doug
used to say
oh my God this is tame
compared to what the real story is right
you know so yeah so I roll my eyeballs
because I just think it's ridiculous and
I think like you know people are
inherently fascinated with our business
and I think you gotta take the good with
the bad and that's a lot there's a lot
of bad it certainly is